Now all of these examples, we're accessing a live
site. But you can also setup Port Forwarding to
allow your mobile device to access a local server
on your development machine over USB. Let's take a look.
To do this, you want to make sure you have
a server running on your local development machine. In
this case, I'm going to use Python's simple HTTP
server on Port 9999. Now to verify that it
is actually working, I'm going to access that on
the local machine and it's working fine. If I
want to now access that same page on my
mobile device, I need to set up Port Forwarding. I
can go back to the Chrome Inspect page, click on Port Forwarding and set up a
port forwarding rule. In this case, port 9999 on local host or
IP address 127001. I enable Port Forwarding and click on Done.
When I refresh this page, you'll see that Port Forwarding is
now running on Port 80 80, and 99 99. At this point,
we're all set up. So let's try it out. I'll open a new tab, navigate
to localhost 9999 on the mobile device. And voila, the page is ready to go.